はい よろしくお願いします
まあ今日はまあこういうテーマで
まあ人間のね まあいろいろ過ち
失敗 どうしましょうかというテーマで
少々お話をしたいと思います
まあできるだけ早いうちに終了いたしますので
皆様にいろいろ疑問 問題あったら
まあその時出してみてください
それで この発展というものはね
あの失敗を直すことですよ
まあ人類が発展しているとかね
文化文明が発展しているとか
まあいろんなことを言ってますけど
結局は何やと よくよく見ると
人間が起こす 犯す あらゆる失敗を一つずつ直していくんです
また二度と同じ失敗を起こさないようにと
そういうことで こういう発展というものは成り立っています
だから 案外失敗はダメということは
それはそういうふうには言えないんですね
人間の歴史は失敗の歴史でもあります
歴史なんか勉強しちゃうと
どうったことがない 誰がどのように失敗したかという話なんです
それにどうしましたかと
それだけの話で まあ成り立ってます
失敗間違いをその都度直すことで今の発展がありますね
社会の発展 科学の発展に失敗は欠かせない条件のようです
だから結局はこれ 失敗することは欠かせない条件になっています
とてもありがたいことですよ
失敗は では 失敗は大いに賛成するべきありがたいことでしょうかと
上の条件を見ると 明らかに失敗がなかったら何にもなりません
ですから 大いに賛成するべきものでしょうか
ということなんですね
で そこで失敗の失敗があるんですよ
ややこしいことをね 失敗は発展に導くならば
これは正しい失敗です
しかし 失敗の失敗もあるんです
一つは失敗すると損するんですよ
政治家が失敗すると全国民が苦労します
全然ありがたくはないんです
政治家とか言ったっても
政治システムですね まあ国ですね
そこは失敗するとみんな大変なことになります
これ 政治の問題でね 虐殺
戦争 人権侵害などの残酷なことに
国民が遭遇しなくてはならない
これは政治家の失敗なんですよ
民族争い 民族浄化  あれこれと起こるんですよ
アメリカなら電話一本もかけられません
全部聞いているんです
友達ででも冗談でお前に爆弾一つ送るぞと言っちゃうと
まあすぐもう FBI が家に来ているという
政治の失敗によって 見せかけの民主主義まで社会が発展している
が 人類が払った代償は多すぎではないでしょうかと
だから今 我々は民主主義世界で生きているんですよ
これ 本物じゃないんです
見せかけなんです 本当は民主主義はまだまだ
まだまだないんです 今ももう権力者
お金がある人は まあ上手に嘘をつく人が政権を取っているんであって
別に一般人の気持ちとして政権
世の中あるわけじゃないんですけど
それでも民主主義は民主主義だからね
何年間経ったところで
ちょっと瞬間だけでも投票する権利がありますからね
その時はあまり投票に行けないようにと色々誘惑しておくんです
で まあだからまあ見せかけの民主主義であっても
我々は昔よりは自由に生きてはいるんです
昔みたいに人間の命をもうあれこれやと愛することは政治にはできません
裁判もありますからね
しかし この状態に達するまで
我々はどれほど一般国民が損してきたかというと
どれほど人々は苦しんできたかと
どれほど人々に人権なく廃人にしたかと
どれぐらい人が殺されたかというと
大変ですよ だから この払った代償とはものすごい多すぎですよ
今も正義の失敗で人類が苦しんでいるんです
では 現代の政治は何なのかというと
ものすごい人々は苦しんでいるんです
だから あの 仏教の話を聞くと
もうちょっと国際的に物事を考えてください
皆様方は日本以外何も存在しないと思っているようですけど
残念なことに日本以外にも物事は存在しているんです
人間がいるんです だからずっと何もわからない
何言ってるの この野郎
この坊主っていう感じで顔するんじゃなくてね
あの 日本はもう完璧じゃないかとか
何の問題もないんだと
そんなことじゃなくて
もうちょこっと日本からね
もう30分行ったところで
別な国なんですよ 別な人間
別な政府 別な政治なんです
ですから 世界的に物事を見てほしいんです
そうでなきゃ 理性あるは知識人とは言えません
ですから 世界的に見てみると
ものすごい人々は未だに徹底的に苦しんでいるんです
ものすごい人々が殺されているんです
アフリカのいろんな国々で
もうもう残酷に殺されているんです
で 昨日も私にメールが来て
もうなんであんなメール来たかわかりませんだけど
このあの 今までまあコネクションできなかった国の人々にまで
我々は我々の活動を広げなくちゃいけないんだから参加してくれませんかと
何やというと このもうアジアンセクター
アフリカンセクターで
こので この人々は仏教だから
イスラム教だからとことんもう自分たちのもうあれ
残酷な戦争争い行ってないんだから教えなくちゃということで
まあ一応キリスト教のなんとかの組織なんですけど
だからまあ 1週間でオリエンテーションを受けて
それからしっかり仕事できますよということで
オリエンテーションのアメリカどこかだからね
私は参加できませんけどね
だからまあ放っておけないんですよ
どこでも人間を苦しめようと思っているんです
で アジアの仏教の国には何のことなく平和でいるんですけど
まあそういう人々が入り込んで
とことん 国の状態も壊しちゃって
あれこれやとやるんですよ
だから世の中は平和ではありません
で まあ特に政治の世界では
もう宗教も絡んでますけど
ものすごい人々が苦しんで死んでいくんですよ
手足切断されて だから昨日か一昨日かテレビ見たならば
道路で人を殺して そのままもうもう引っ張ったりして
だからまあ想像できませんよ
もう毎日自分の目の前で爆弾を起こして
もう殺すわ もうまたもう殺した人が道路で車に何かにつけて痛いようにあちこち見せながら持っていくわとかね
だから今も世の中 人間っていうのはものすごく苦しんでいるんです
理由はシステムの失敗なんですよ
誰かの気が立ったら もうやりたい放題やっちゃうという
まあクーデターでも取って
政権取った人が自分の民族以外の民族は全部殺してやるぞと
で まあそういう世界で我々は生きてるんで
だから昔だけ苦しんだわけじゃなくて
政治の失敗でいまだに人々は苦しんでいる
だから私のポイントは
失敗っていうのは大いに喜ぶ
喜ぶべきものでもありません
失敗のおかげで我々は発展はしていく
だからといって失敗は賛成できるのかっていうことなんです
科学の場合は失敗だけではなく
成功も人類に迷惑をかけてきたんですよ
それで科学になってくると
失敗は人間に迷惑じゃなくだけではなくて
成功したっても迷惑なんです
まあ例えば原子力の開発っていうのは成功でしょ
これでものすごい迷惑なんです
自然の破壊 新たな病 戦争の拡大などにも科学が大いに貢献しているんです
だから 現代のあらゆる一切の苦しみの裏にいるのは科学なんです
科学がなかったらこんな自然破壊あるわけじゃないでしょうに
飲み水もなくなるわけじゃないでしょうに
それからいっぱい雨が降ってますよ
でも地球上の水の量は
真水の量はもう計算していますよ
もうそんな残ります もう何年かなと
なくなるんだそうです
ですから 今商売やってる人は必死でこの水の資源をね
独占しようと競争しているんです
それで儲かりますよと
みんなに飲み水がなくなったら
だから科学者に応援している
とにかく早くやってくださいと
この水を枯れることを
その方がもう金の値段で水は売れますよということを思っているんです
だから聞きたいんですけど
こんなに世界でね 一流の大量にきれいな水がある日本の人々は
なんでいつでもペットボトルで飲んでるんですかね
なんとかもう水を 世界中どこへ行ってもこんなきれいな水がないんですけど
知らないんでしょうね
その理由はやられてるんです
将来の搾取によく乗ってます
こんなの断っちゃえば作りませんよ
人類の半分以上貧困に陥っているのに
科学のために制限なく人類の財産を費やしているんです
それで科学研究あれやこれやと言って
もうほとんど地球の財産はね
それに使っている しかし
ものすごい貧困ですよ
1 分に一人ぐらい子供は死んでますけど
それは全然気にもしない
すべての生命を幸福にしてあげる目的は科学者にはありません
科学者のやるのは科学の研究だけ
人間は関係ないんです
ただ研究すればいい ただ何か知らないものを発見すればいいと
これ過去とかを思い出してのは
日本のノーベル賞を取ったあのニュートリノを発見した科学者のことなんです
ん？はい あのぶどうっておじい様の東大の名誉教授
湯川さんじゃなく ん？まあまあまあ
四年 三年ぐらい前でしょ
そんな遠いところじゃないんです
ニュートリノという素粒子を発見して
ノーベル賞を取ったと
よく面白くて すごい優しく
自分がどのように研究したか
どれぐらい苦労したかっていう
すごい説明するんですけど
私はそれ聞いて それぐらいお金かけてあんた何やったんですか？って
ただ ニュートリノっていうのは
あることは論理的にはずっと知っていたんですけど
まあ立証できなかっただけだと
だから立証できたと だから
全くもつかむところない
つかめない すごい微妙な粒子なんですよ
だからもう 1 分ごとにもう何トンも量のニュートリノが地球通って出ていくんです
我々の体も全部通して
そんなすごいものあるんだそうで
あったって体に触れないものだから関係ないでしょうね
地球にも触れないんだから
地球通っていくんだから
まあだからそんなものはあるんだそうというだけで終わっちゃうんです
あ びっくりと だから大人なのに
あ びっくりというぐらいのことにそこまでやるんだから
だから何億ですかね その研究に
だからその先生が悪い
頭悪いとか何とかっていうことじゃないんです
科学はそういうものなんです
ただやるだけ で まあ危険な失敗
医学と医者の失敗はありがたくないでしょう
原子力発電所の失敗 飛行機操縦士の失敗
電車運転手の失敗などもあまりありがたくはないんですよ
親の失敗も教師の失敗も
人に末永く不幸を与える可能性があるんです
それは可能性 確実ということではないんですけど
時々親が失敗してしまうと
この人がもう死ぬまでそれで引きずって困ることもあります
教師が失敗したところで
もう本当に頭のいい人なのに
もう全く何もできなくて
人生全部不幸になる可能性もあります
だから失敗といったっても
そういう危険であってはならない失敗もあります
要するに失敗は損です
発展のための失敗を認めると赤字ですよ
人生は だから失敗がなければ発展しない
我々の社会は だから これ
発展に必要な大事な要因だから
じゃあありがたくしましょうで言っちゃうと
ものすごい損するんです
どれほど人が不幸になるか
どれほど地球が破壊するか
どれほど人を殺すか分からなくなっちゃうんですよ
だから発展を目指しても
発展というのはいつでもすごい赤字なんです
いつでも人間は代償としてものすごい大量のものを払って
ほんの少々の得を いるだけの世界なんです
そういうわけで そのセクションの結論は
まあ認めるか認めるべきべからずかということなんですね
もう失敗は これ本当にジレンマなんですよ
エラーのジレンマを乗り越えないんですよ
そういうわけで いつでもエラーが起きちゃうし
エラーがなくてはならないし
あってもならないし 人は失敗しちゃうと
もうものすごく大変なことになる
失敗しなかったら何の成長も成長もなくなったりする
だからどうするのかという
それはものすごいジレンマで矛盾なんですね
それなのに人間は まず人間は一方的に失敗ということはなくそうとするんです
あれは失敗はね 損だと思ってるんだからなんです
失敗のジレンマを知らないが
損だけは嫌なのです あまり人間
この失敗ということは
すごいジレンマであることを矛盾であることを知らないんです
どうにもならない矛盾ですよ
やるかやらないか どちらでもダメなんですよ
失敗してもダメでしないこともダメなんです
それはわからないんだけど
かなり損しているということだけを知っている
だから失敗なくそうとしているんです
失敗をなくそうとする
失敗を減らそうとする人も
失敗をなくそうではなくて
減らそうとする人はたまにいるんです
だから減らそうとする方がマシですけど
減らそうとはしないんで
なくそうと だからとんでもない失敗するんです
これが新たな問題を引き起こすんです
この失敗をなくそうすることで
またものすごい新しい問題が起こるんです
新しい失敗です それも
新たなジレンマを作るんです
ですから 失敗をなくすということも
結局また失敗なんです
失敗を完全になくすということは
成長発展を停止することです
この場合は 国であろう
社会であろう 動きが停止して衰退して消えるんです
だからいろいろ文明とか消えたでしょ
消えるんです それなりに発展して
まあ我々はもう結構十分な状態になりましたと
そこで落ち着いて安静安心するんです
それでそれ文明が滅びるんです
この古代巨大文明というのは
そういうふうに滅びていったんです
毎日のように失敗していたならば
頑張っているはずなんです
だから国もそういうふうに
もう そこは失敗 消えちゃうと停滞して衰退して滅びてはいくんです
例えば政府が政治がいろんな悪いことをやったりすると
国民が元気だったら毎日それに何とか言ったり
なんとか言ったりとか
ギャーギャー文句言ったり
いろんなことをやっているんです
だから 日本以外の国々は
もう国民も結構元気ですよ
なぜかというと 政府はだらしないんだから
もう朝から晩まででももう悪口言いたいことはいっぱいあります
黙ってはいないんです
だからそれで国民 一応国がそれで活気を持って生きているんです
失敗をなくす注意で 経済的
時間的 精神的能力という面で余計な負担がかかります
それで失敗をなくしてもダメですよ
そこで失敗をなくそうなくそうとすごく注意するでしょうね
この失敗しないように注意することで
すごい時間かかっちゃうんですよ
仕事に 早く仕事をすることはできなくなります
仕事に時間かかると間に合わなくなっちゃいます
人生は まあ例えば大きなダムを作ろうと計画を立てる
そこは実行せろで 何も失敗なく
しっかり作ろうというと
これはもうせいぜい 50年ぐらいゆっくり作らなくちゃいけないんですよ
50年  60年ぐらいかけて
そうすると もう今生きている人々にとっては何の意味もないんです
苦労してお金かけて作るだけで
そうすると 50年後でダムができても
その時社会がなおさら変わっているんだから
そんなもんで足りない
こんな古い昔の計画で今意味がないんだと
もしかするとその国はもう水力発電は使わないことになっているかもしれません
ダムはできたんですけども
もういらないと 結構そういうことはあります
世の中で だから失敗しないように注意しちゃうと
時間なくかかってしまって
また無駄になるという失敗もあります
それから あの これ経済的
すごくお金がかかりますよ
例えば家庭でお母さんが何のことなくろくに手も洗わないで料理作って食べさせていますけど
誰も病気になりませんし
それはもう食品工場でやる場合はものすごい衛生管理で
もうもう何段階も分けて体きれいにして
空気まできれいにして
服を着替えて 口を閉めて
目全部手足全部閉めて動かないようにして
これすごくお金かかっちゃうんです
だからつまらないものはものすごい高い値段で買わなくちゃいけないんですよ
それから精神的にものすごい規則
決まりがいっぱいありすぎちゃって
精神的にもすごくストレスになっちゃう
そういうことにだけ頭がいくんだから
仕事の能力向上にはもう考える余裕
暇がなくなるんです そういうことで
本当は余計な負担がたくさんかかるんですよ
失敗なくそうっていうことで
楽じゃないんで 失敗なくすっていうことは
結局は失敗をなくすことは様々な失敗を引き起こすんです
だから こちらに書いたものも失敗ですから
失敗なくそうとすることも結局は失敗になるんです
失敗する人を批判 非難したりする
それからもう性格の悪さといえば
世の中の みんな堂々と失敗しているのに
人が失敗すると飛んで行って
そこは非難するは 侮辱するは
まあきりがないんです
そうなってくると なおさら苦しくなるんです
社会システムが 他人の失敗を徹底的に非難しながら
自分の失敗を徹底的に隠すんです
これはよく社会で起きているでしょうに
マスコミなんかは人の失敗だったら
まあ言うわ言うわ言うわ言うわ
人の家まで飛び入り入り込んだりして
家もずっと周り囲い込んでいて
で 自分たちもっとひどい汚い醜いことをやってますけど
それをちゃらっと隠すんです
NHK もそうでしょうに
偉大なる NHK も もうやりたい放題我々やって
それは何で何のこともない
それちゃらちゃらっと消すんです
瞬時に 社会は互いに非難を投げかけ合いというね
まあそういう合戦しているんです
だから社会システムどういうことか
とにかく相手のことを非難する
相手もこちらのことを非難する
非難しようと思ったらいくらでも人間に失敗あるんだから
いくらでももう燃料あるんですよ
燃やそうとすれば だから人は誰でも失敗する
失敗なくそうと思っちゃうと
これまた失敗するし それは世の中普通自然にあることで
その上性格が悪くて あなたがなんで失敗したのかとか
なんでこんな失敗するのかというと
相手を非難しちゃうと相手も同じ合戦しますから
こちらにもいっぱいこちらのものを隠そうとした
あんた隠そうしたんではないかとかね
そこまでになるんだから
もう世界はどうにもならない
醜い生き苦しい世界に
社会になっているんです
他人の失敗を認めないことで争いが起こる
それから他人の失敗は認めないんだから
あらゆる争い起こるんですよ
戦いに行くんです あなたは悪いことをしたんだから
ただですみませんよと
それはもうしっかりしなくちゃいけないんだよと
例えば現代起きてる戦争っていうのは
いろんな国々が失敗するんだから
アメリカが警察官になってこれを正そうとしているんです
アフガニスタンの生き方を正そうと
パキスタンを直してやろうと
イラクを直してやろうとかね
なぜならば自分たちは完璧な政治やってますから
何の間違いもなく 自分の国ではピストルがないと生きていられないんですけど
それで結局ありえないんです
そんなことは だから誰でも間違いを起こす
それで自分の間違いを置いといて
他人の間違いを直してやろうと思う
お釈迦様は随分簡単に
そんなもうあまりこういうことは詳しくは言いませんだけど
まあ言ってはありますけどね
もうあてにならんと そういう人間で期待さえもできん
できんやと 失敗を怯える個人は精神的に落ち込む
だから個人的には我々は失敗っていうのは当たり前ではなくて
怯えるんです だって世の中鬼だらけだから
いきなり鬼たちが上がってきてもう攻撃するんだから
鬼たちみんな人類が鬼たちで自分を攻撃しようと思ってますけど
個人一人に失敗しない生き方はできませんよ
ということは 生きることそのものが否定するやり方なんです
生きることさえも不可能にするんです
どんな人でも何か失敗をする
そうすると 周りの鬼たちがいきなり呪文魔法をかけたような感じで立ち上がってくるんです
だから そういうイメージで考えてみれば
周りにいるのは人間じゃなくて
みんなものすごく恐ろしい鬼たちである
しかし なんとなくまあもう居眠りはしているんですけど
こちらに魔法をかけた途端
もう立ち上がって凶暴になって攻撃する
魔法にかけられているんだから
自己管理はできません
相手をもう滅多打ちにして潰すまでやるんです
そういうわけで 個人がものすごく精神的に落ち込んだり
自殺したり 大変なことになるんです
失敗をなくす努力も 様々な失敗を引き起こすうすうす巻きになる結果ですね
ですから だから社会がなんで私の失敗を非難するのかというと
失敗をなくすつもりなんです
そういうことで 一人一人の人間にも生きていられない世界を作るんです
これはなおさら失敗なんですよ
損するだけで終わる失敗じゃなくて
生きることさえも不可能にする失敗ですから
宇宙開発にロケットを作ったことで
これでまあ 3 秒で 300億円飛ばしちゃったとなくなったと言ったっても
それで人類が生きていられなくなるぐらいはないんです
まあ 5年も計画立てて
ものすごいお金がかかって
ロケットを作って またなんとか衛星も作って飛ばそうしたところで
すぐ爆発したんだと だから
まあそれでそのお金がなくなっただけで
まあ少ない損で終わりますけど
我々の生き方はどう生き方かというと
失敗しないような生き方をしているんだから
ですから 生きることさえもできない状況を作るというすごい失敗
もう最大の失敗をするということになるんです
だからその まあもう今これ結論なんですけど
今まで話したことの結論といえば何でしょうかというと
これ 吾輩は完璧であるという考え方なんです
だから人のことは平気で批判で非難できます
問題はこちらにあるんです
ありえないでしょうし
しかしそう思っているんです
エラーや失敗をなくす衝動は完璧主義という邪見です
だから完璧主義というとてつもない恐ろしい邪見が
各個人が持っているんです
それで本人もあらゆる精神的な病気になるし
周りにも平和で生かしてはあげません
周りもとにかく不幸に引きずっていくんです
で 問題はなんでそんなに不完全が嫌ですかね
嫌だから吾輩は完璧やという頭心の中で思っているんだから
損する危険という立場では
失敗は 認めることはできません
それぐらいわかりますよ
すごい損するんだから失敗するなよと
危険だから失敗するなよと
はいいんです しかし 完璧主義で失敗するなよということはどういうことでしょうかと
普通だったらまあ失敗はいろいろあるんだけど
この失敗だけしないでくれと
これだけは失敗しないでくれと言った方がいいんです
なぜかというと その 1個 2個の失敗しちゃうと損するし
危険であるしということで
しかし なぜ失敗したら精神的に落ち込むんでしょうかね
しかし そんな危険でも何もないし
誰にも 損したわけでもないのに
ちょっとした失敗でものすごく落ち込むんです
ちょっと言葉を間違っただけで
まあすごいことを ものすごく落ち込んだりするんです
なんでそんなにもちょっとした失敗にそれほど神経質になって興奮したり
感情的になって攻撃するでしょうかというと
この不完全は嫌なんですね
すごい偉い 相当偉いんです
不完全はもう認めたくないんです
自分の心は失敗を認めないからです
だから人間っていうのは
自分に対してどれほど
高く評価しているのかというと
自分がもうちょこっとでも失敗を認めません
だから自分が何か失敗しても
それでひどく本人が悩んだりするし
世界の失敗間違いに対してはもう鬼になってとことん攻撃してやるぞと思っちゃうんです
本当にそこまで自分のことを思うんですかね
町な人間なら いかに人間として情けない子
だらしない品格のないかというと
なぜ人は他人のことを厳しく批判するのでしょうか
そういう理由なんです
自分は失敗しない完璧者だからです
だから他人のことは厳しく批判するんです
自分が完璧だからね 自分が完璧だと思ってないならば
人のことはそんな風には言えませんよ
人は不完全 言ったのは誰と誰ですかね
ことわざもあるでしょ
有名なことわざもあります
トゥエリースヒューマン
トゥフォーギブイズディバインということわざもあります
まあ それは完全な方々はそんなこと知らんでしょうとも思いますけどね
有名な言葉ですけど 完全であるはずの人間は自分の過ちで不完全になったのだという矛盾を一心教は語る
これはこの人間は不完全だという考え方は西洋というか
東洋の思考じゃないんです
東洋にないわけじゃなくて
皆様よく乗って言ってる言葉っていうのは西洋から来たもので
被り物でなきゃみんなもう使わないんだから
自分のものを捨てますからね
まあそういうまあ西洋の思考なんですよ
西洋の思考っていうのは
人間は神様が作ったんですから
人間は完璧なんです 神の作品だから
しかし 人間がやった過ちで不完全になりましたと
よくあんなことをのこのこと言うんでしょうね
完璧に作ったものは過ちを作らないでしょうに
そんな程度の知恵なんですよ
とことん乗ってください
完璧に作ったならば過ちは犯しません
ただ 神話から解説するならば
悪魔の誘惑は効きませんよ
蛇が来て誘惑したって話でしょ
だから言ってることは初めから矛盾です
それだけじゃなくて なんか不完全であることは過ち
間違いなんですよ 西洋ではというか
中東かな 世にあるのはこの教えです
だからこの人は不完全ということは
まあそういう いわゆるキリスト教文化から入り込んでいるものなんです
だから不完全であることはあってはならない
もうとんでもないことで
ということになるんです
ですから 人は生きる上での完全を目指すことに挑戦している
そういう考え方があるんだから
一生懸命完全になろうではないかという挑戦をするんです
それも生きてる上 生きてること
だから美を完成しようと金を儲けて完成しようとか
健康で完成しようとか
権力で完成しようとか
いろいろやっています
明らかに俗世間での完成を目指しているんです
だから 地球上のほとんどの人々は貧困に陥って
もうあらゆる不幸 不平不満にやられて生活しなくちゃいけないんです
一部が完成を目指しているんだから
建前で人は間違いを起こすと言いながら
本音で認めたくはないんです
人は不完全 不完全だとは仏教の言葉ではありません
ですから 人は不完全だとは仏教は言っていないんです
だったら何言ってますかね
すべては不完全ですというのは仏教の言葉なんです
すべては不完全で無常です
これはすごい違うんですよ
で 人間だけ不完全ですよ
西洋では神は完全です
仏教ではすべて一切不完全で
完全なものはもう成り立ちません
ありともしないんです
特別人間ということじゃないんです
すべては不完全だ 無常だと仏教は説く
それなら生きる上では完全はありえないんです
全くありえないことに挑戦しているんです
すべて不完全だから だから無理に挑戦すると
それ自体またさらに苦しくなるでしょうに
すべて不完全だから放っておけというのは仏教的な立場なんです
気楽にいなさいよと その目的の努力は矛盾的な行為になるので
なおさら問題を引き起こすんです
ちょっと難しい文章になってますけど
この生きる上での完成というのはありえないんですよ
その努力なんかは矛盾なんです
生きる上で完成は成り立ちません
一切は無常です ですから
我々やっている日常生活になってやっているどんな行為を見ても
必ず矛盾です 必ず矛盾になるんです
それで何とか良くしよう
良くしようと思っちゃうと
なおさら悪くなるんです
面白い世界で生きているんですよ
なんとか良くしようと思っちゃうと
前よりはひどくなっちゃうんです
それが考え方 恐ろしい邪見ですからね
完成はありえないと知る人はベターに挑戦するんです
あれ ベストではなくて
まあいくら不完全でも
ちょこっと微妙にちょこっとちょこっとベターの方は
できるでしょうと だからベターっていうことは完全ではないって意味なんです
だから少々ベターベターに
少々よりちょこっとより良くなりましょうと
だからより良くなりましょうというところは具体的で
ものすごい理性なんですよ
もうちょっとマシになれないのかぐらいで十分です
それだったらすごい具体的で
まあ楽しく生きていられます
だから人間はもう少々マシになろうよということで生きていればいいのに
これがもう正義の味方がいるわ
もうもう世界は完成にするぞというわ
神様はもうそろそろ来るんだそうですよ
この社会は全部壊して完璧な社会を作るために
この間新宿で言っていたんですけどね
ベストはないんです だからベストを尽くすっていう風に普通は言うんだけど
ベターになればいいんですけどね
人がベストを尽くしたって
あなたのベストそんな程度かと聞きたくなりますけどね
ということは それ以上は期待できませんだからね
その人からは すぐ会社だったらクビにした方がいいんです
私はベスト あ そう じゃあそんな程度だから
じゃああんた今日から辞めてくださいと
だからベターをね やればいいのに
そうすると社長にじゃあ明日もうちょこっと
今日よりはもうちょっといいことにしてくださいと
言えば それが具体的でできるはずなんです
はい それからタイトル変えました
失敗の原因というところで
行為とは自分と他人の関わりですね
行為というのは まあ生きるということは自分と他人の関わりなんですよ
他人も 2種類です 生き物と物です
だから自分が生き物と関わるか
ものと関わるかということが生きることなんです
自然の流れはいくらかわかっているが
先を読めないことはあるんです
では ものに関わる 例えば農業をやっている人は土と関わっているんですよ
土はものですよ 文句も言いませんし
黙っているし だから自分好きなように土をいじることはできます
なぜならば いくらか土の法則を知っていますが
それでも読めないんです
先は 生き物の場合はほとんど先を読めないんです
例えば 今年の田んぼにカモたちが飛んできて
あの田んぼの中であちこちあちこちうろうろしていて
雑草を食べてくれて ものすごい豊作になりましたと
いろいろね まあ鳥たちがね
まあ田んぼで餌取っちゃうと
この泥の中に空気を入れてくれるし
だからもう稲の根のところがね
くちばしさせてますからね
植物にとってはすごいありがたい環境で
人間触るとしぼんで死にますけど
動物触るとすごく元気になっちゃうんです
で そうするとそれが豊作になる
それでその農業を営んだ方が
じゃあ来年もじゃあカモたちに任せましょうと思ったって
来るか来ないかわからないんですよ
そんなのは 生き物の先は読めないんです
だから物質の先はいくらか読めますけど
それでも読めないんだからね
という条件の中で行為なんですよ
だから結局は先が読めない条件の中で生きてるんだから
うまくいったり期待外れたりですよ
だから自分で成功したっていうことは成り立ちません
逆に自分で失敗したっていうことも成り立ちません
田んぼに水が入らなかったら田んぼは失敗ですけど
私は失敗したっていうことじゃないんです
水も入って 鳥たち 白鷺たちやらいっぱい入ってきて
田んぼは住みかにして
もう遊んでいて それで豊作になったら
あ 今年私は成功しましたよと言えたものじゃないんです
だから普通の人生っていうのはそういうものなんです
成功したっても 自分がやったということは全然言えませんよ
だって自分の関わりが生き物と物の関わりだから
うまくいったんだからといって
自分の特権ということでもないし
失敗したっても自分の責任ということでもないんですね
だからそこはあまり仏教以外はあまり認めないことですけどね
また 行為をする側も生き物なので
自分であっても自分のことほとんど読めないんですよ
だから自分が行為してるんだから
自分が生き物でしょうね
だから自分でも自分のことを知らないんです
うまく仕事をできる気分でいるか
仕事をしなくちゃいけないんだけど
その気になるかならないかとか
自分でもわからない だからなおさら難しいんですよ
環境が良くても自分が失敗する場合があります
環境っていうのは あの 2つの条件
田んぼもよくできたし
水もあるし もう鳥たちも来ているし
環境はいいんだけど 自分が失敗する可能性はあります
自分が良くても環境のことで失敗することもあります
環境が良くても 自分が生き物だから
自分もね だから自分のせいで失敗する場合もあるし
もう自分が頑張っているのに環境がちょこっと悪くて失敗する可能性もあります
ですから 成功するケースよりは失敗するケースの方が確率は高いんです
だから 実際 世の中ではいつでもあり得ることは失敗なんです
成功っていうのは確実にあり得るものじゃないんです
この先が読めないことで生きてるんだから
くじと同じですよ くじは引いたら必ず一等賞を引くとか
そんなありえないでしょうに
くじっていうのはもう負けるようにという感じで作るもんですよ
そういうわけで 正しく具体的に客観的に物事を見るならば
失敗することっていうのはすごく当たり前で
成功するということはすごい確率は少ない
低い 無知な人はこの現実を認めないので
さらに苦労するんです
しかし 世の中はこれ認めないんですよ
このこの事実を 仏教はこう言うんです
仏教は来いと言ったって
誰が頭のことをちょっとレントゲンででも見てもらいたいんですけど
だから無知な世界は本当にもう
なおさらもう余計に余計に苦しみを苦しみを作って作って
どんどん世界も人類も破壊
破壊へもう押すんですよ
それが失敗の原因ですよ
失敗の原因っていうのはすごいシンプルですよ
私が行為して失敗するか成功する
私は行為する場合は ものと関わるか
生命と関わるか どちらでも先は何をやってくれるかわからないんです
そうすると 自分が頑張っても結果がどちらに出るかわからない
だって自分も生き物だから
うまくできるかできないかってことは
自分で自身でもわからない
そういうところの成功だから
成功っていうのはまぐれなんですよ
うまく噛み合わせたっていうところは成功なんです
ですから このあまりにも正しく生きていようと今思うと
これこうどうやって読むんですかね
憂鬱 憂鬱 憂鬱になってしまいますけど
それは避けられますよ
本当は 10個仕事をすると9個失敗して1個だけ成功すると
やっぱり憂鬱になっちゃいますよ
なんでこの人生は？とではなくて
人生はそんなもんなんです
そういうわけで 別に憂鬱になる必要はないんです
それは避けられます ただ
ちょこっと理性があればいいんです
失敗を認めない人は いくらチェックをして頑張っても
失敗の方が確率が高いなので
落ち込むしか悩むしかありません
だから失敗を認めないならば
どうぞ落ち込んでくださいと
もう怒れてくださいと
将来はなしと あなたには
で むちゃくちゃ失敗しているのに
何のこともなく 次に次に次に次に頑張っている人はもう次々行くんです 10
回挑戦すれば1回はうまくいくとかね
で 10回もうまくいかなかったら
また11回目もやってみて
20回目もやってみて
もしかすると 34回目でうまくいく可能性はあります
そういうことで 何のことなく
まあもうやる人には憂鬱はないんです
仏教では高い確率の失敗が起きても
それは当たり前のことで
低い確率の成功が起きたらとても明るい気分になります
だから仏教的に見ると
あ 失敗しました あ またこれも失敗しました
あれも失敗 まあそれは当たり前だから
失敗するのは当たり前のことで
そこでやっている時にうまくいったら
これびっくり あ うまくいったと
なんてことですかと だから仏教の人はいつでもすごい明るいんです
嘘かどうか 試しに行ってみてください
仏教の環境があるところに
キリスト教の人々はすごくありがたく
貧困ではないかとかね
だからいじめてやろうと思っていますけど
本当に私もすごい これだけはもうもうなんとかしてでも止めなくちゃいけないと思ってますよ
ハチャメチャにするんだから
この人々がいて あの人々はもうハットでもう住むところなかったら
どこかで横になって寝ていたっても
ものすごく明るいんです
人のこと心配する 人の痛みも全部悲しみもわかるな
感じている 知らない人が来たっても
自分に何もなくても なんとか作ってご飯でも食べさせようとする
それで商売しようと思ってないんです
だから そんなにもう地球上で一番正しい生き方をしている人々に
神のメッセージを教えてあげなくちゃいけないよと
殺せ 殺せという だから本当にこの仏教の世界の人々は
この余計な哲学も何も知らん
ただ単に明るくしているだけ
何かうまくいったらものすごく喜ぶんです
うまくいかなかったら
ああそう それで終わり
トラブル 問題 障害などを乗り越えることが人生だと知っているので
精神的に安定して着々と生きることができるのです
これ 仏教的な 仏教的な人だったら
生きるということは トラブルを乗り越えること
障害を乗り越えること
それが生きることよ だから毎日何かあるんだよと
毎日何かトラブルが待ち構えているんです
ないわけじゃないんです
毎日頑張っても全部成功するということでもないんです
それが人生だと知ってますから
別に何のこともなく 着々と
だからやめたら意味がないでしょな
嫌だからやめたとかね
苦しいんだからやめたとか
面白くないんだからやめたとか
なんだ その考え方は まあ動物より以下でしょうね
動物は嫌だからやめるってことないでしょうね
獲物を取るのは嫌だ あの獲物が逃げるんだから
あいつ逃げる どうやって私は獲物取るんでしょう
そんなこと動物言うんですかね
時々この肉食動物は獲物を取って
カモを殺しても 草食動物を攻撃するんだから
角とか持ってますから
それでやられちゃうとすっごい怪我したりもしますよ
それでやっぱり危ないんだから
怪我死するんだから 私は獲物取りませんとかね
そんな動物さえないのに
これ人間っていうのは嫌だからやめたと
学校で隣に座ってる人が臭いと言ったんだから
私はもうもう何て言いますか
学校に行くことをやめましたと
それって人間でしょうかと
もし私がその年で隣の人が臭いと言ったならば
何のことなく黙ってるんです
すっごくひどく悩んだ状態
顔を見せていて いて 本当に便所から臭いものを持って行ってあげるんです
カバンにでも入れておくんです
で 何か見つけたら だってあんた臭いと言ったっても
あれとあの程度で臭くないんだからね
今臭いでしょうと 本当に
そんなこと ったら大体まあ七
八年ぐらいはそげでもちますよ
人間らしからんだから
何問題置くたっても解決法ないんですよ
どうすればいいか それより先に人間になりなさいよと思う
もうもうなんか犬猫に数学を教えるようなもんでしょうに
できないでしょうに よく困ることというのは
犬っていうのは猫でも同じけど
家に入るとドアを開けることは堂々と学んでますけど
ドア閉めるよと言ったって全然閉めません
開けて入る それで終わり
だからこれ 犬にも猫にも
いくら頑張っても閉めるということを教えられません
というのは その概念はその世界でないんです
閉めて身を隠すということはないんです
逃げて身を隠すんですよ
動物は 何か閉めて隠れていることはないんです
逃げて身を隠す ですから
家には入ります 窓を開けて
飼っている犬は猫は だから開けては入るんですけど
閉めるということはしない
そこでどこかと他の野良猫に追っかけ追いかけたならば
さっさと来て自分の窓に飛んで
窓の雨戸を開けて中に入るんですけど
そこから野良猫も入ったならば
どうしますかね あの猫は隠れるんです
だから 本人いや これ閉めちゃえば大丈夫やと思う
それは知らないんです
だからもうそういうその世界で
この人間は人間のレベルからもうもうドーンと落ちちゃって
あまりにもスピード もうとにかくスピードに挑戦するんだから
落ちる時でもスピードに挑戦して
ちょっと落ちすぎですよ
これはもう動物のレベルよりも落ちているんです
だから毎日のトラブルは自分で乗り越えることはできない
生きることっていうのは
死ぬまでもうずっとトラブルの連続ですよ
トラブルがなかったら生きるっていうことじゃないんです
トラブルが嫌な人はもう引きこもりで部屋の中に隠れていなくちゃいけないんです
何もしないで それで生きる気がしませんでしょうに
生きる気がしたければ
あらゆるトラブルがあってもあっても
気にしないで 先へ先へ先へ着々と進むことなんです
そういうことで 仏教の世界は
生きるということは大変幸福なものやとは言いません
毎日何かにぶつかりますよと
一つうまく避けたなと思ったら
またそれ避けたことで別な風にぶつかっています
もう  そういうことです
それで だから失敗をなくすということがあり得ない矛盾です
しかし 仏教はこの矛盾をどうやって乗り越えるのか
矛盾のない世界を教えるんです
ヒューマンエラーを減らす中世の立場があるんです